au coeur de kharkiv cet immeuble a été
touché de plein fouet le bâtiment est
presque totalement détruit visé par
plusieurs bombardements dans la deuxième
ville du pays
je pense qu'ils font exprès de détruire
ces infrastructures civiles
jusqu'ici il y eu plus de morts civiles
que militaires
c'est évident que c'est un génocide
contre notre nation
est né
non loin de là un autre bombardement a
provoqué cet incendie que les pompiers
tentent de stopper la région de kharkiv
a été la cible une nouvelle fois de
nombreux tirs avec au moins cinq
personnes tuées des petits russes qui se
poursuivent également dans l'est du pays
ici dans cette petite ville proche de
cramât tort sq ce missile est planté en
plein milieu de ce champ il a été tiré
en pleine nuit blessant notamment une
personne âgée dans une maison juste à
côté
c'est un missile touch calme une fusée
russe cela fait longtemps qu'ils nous
menacent de tirer des armes de cette
taille est maintenant le moment est venu
de chasse de ce que nous assistons ces
derniers jours à une offensive sur le
territoire et des combats sévères ont
lieu pour tenter de contrer ces attaques
l'ukraine espère accélérer les
livraisons d'armes ce mardi une
quarantaine de pays dont les états unis
sont d'ailleurs réunis en allemagne pour
renforcer les défenses ukrainienne